hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
october
11th
2021 what's going on how are ya
how are you dude what's the deal with
daylight savings
daylight savings they're not gonna
they're not gonna fall back
i choose to fight back what movie was
that
um they they're not going to fall back
until [ __ ] november
used to be like in october you know what
i mean
what are we doing the fall
is supposed to be dark
right
this is when you start making your
pumpkin bread the kids go
trick-or-treating
supposed to start snowing
no they want the [ __ ] sun out all day
all day so you can go to work
you know unless you're still collecting
checks you [ __ ] sneeze and [ __ ]
um
duh yeah so they're not gonna they're
not gonna
they are not going to turn the clocks
but let's see daylight savings daylight
savings
is from march 14th now till november 7th
it used to be october
until april
so now it's basically uh let's see april
may june july august september october
november eight [ __ ] months
oh god
is this because there's so many
depressed people out there
um
like tyson fury he was talking about how
he was all uh
depressed and all that he had all the
belts and all that i didn't i didn't uh
read too much on that i did watch that
fight did you guys see the fight i
watched the fight
um
yeah i saw that
i don't think i'm into boxing anymore
just watching those guys just one
[ __ ] punch after another to the head
and like post cte
just watching the punishment and now the
big thing is they cut to the crowd so
they can show their wives the wife of
the fighter that's losing crying it's
just like
jesus christ
i felt horrible for the other guy
um
tyson fury reminds me of uh did you ever
see that movie a long time are you old
like me they used to have these monster
movies called it was called creature
double feature
and uh
there was this b movie called the
amazing colossal man
i've talked about this before
and uh it was sort of like ahead of its
time as far as
talking about how shitty the [ __ ]
military treats the troops
you know because back in the day you
know they they ignite an atomic bomb and
they just made these guys this whole
platoon or whatever walk towards it to
see what would happen in the event if
they did something like that and like
they all died of cancer because of the
radiation
so anyways this movie i think sort of
goes to address that i don't know
so this this guy is in the army an
atomic bomb goes off
and he gets [ __ ] you know all his
clothes get blown off or anything no
full frontal
it's the 1950s it was a conservative
time they didn't have his wang hanging
out he should have he should have his
1950s dick hanging out he probably would
have got a [ __ ] oscar
you know that was such a brave
performance to have your ding-dong
[ __ ] swirling around there was a man
five feet away with a fan
blowing on your dick and balls making
them flip-flop
as you landed in the dirt
you know
simulating standing near an atomic bomb
and the oscar goes to
dick and balls
the amazing colossal man so anyway the
uh result of that
in the movie was the guy just starts
growing uncontrollably
and uh
it's [ __ ] you know he just he kept
getting bigger and bigger and they were
trying to help him out it was [ __ ]
with his temperament i i rewatched the
movie about a year ago
and then there's a part in the end they
[ __ ] you know
the army takes him out he falls into
like the hoover dam
spoiler alert right and he just goes
head first and then that's the end
the amazing colossal man goes headfirst
into the [ __ ] hoover dam
and then
but it was you know it's a complex
character like he was he didn't want to
keep growing obviously he felt alienated
he felt he felt like
not one with everybody else and then he
was slowly losing his mind i think
because he was growing or whatever and
then in the end
the army that he served and ended up
taking him out so there was a lot for
that actor to do
and then the second one he just crawls
out of the hoover dam and his head's all
[ __ ] up and his face is all [ __ ] up
but he's just walking around going
that's the performance the whole movie
and i'm thinking that guy's gotta be
like well how much are you gonna pay me
i just gotta grunt for [ __ ] 90
minutes i get another check all right
well i mean
i thought the original amazing colossal
man was gonna lead to something
so anyway
to see a six foot nine
you know boxer like that's what he he
tyson fury is like the real version i
feel the amazing colossal man the guy
steps over the top rope like [ __ ]
andre the giant
and uh six foot nine and can slip
punches i mean he's both of them were
amazing
uh to watch it was a hell of a fight but
i you know jesus christ the [ __ ]
punishment
that those two guys did to each other my
god and both of them like a [ __ ]
rocky fight they'd go down and then they
get back up
i mean you have to i i'm not big bucks
was it dante wilder's name was that a
safety on tampa i have no [ __ ] idea
okay
i got so much [ __ ] going on and i got
two kids under the age of four i can't
keep anybody's name straight
now god damn it the guy went in there
and he [ __ ] anytime you box you risk
your life so i got to make sure i get
this guy's name right
uh
tyson fury versus wilder all
right
okay
all right do i got it did i say
deontay i hope i said that right um
anyway
um
both of those guys just going down and
then coming back up and and fighting
again it was just it was
it was an amazing fight but i got to be
honest with you just watching that
you know i just thought both of them
it's like i hope they both retire soon
you know they get millions for this just
keep your [ __ ] money
spend it wisely
don't try to save your whole [ __ ]
family and neighborhood in the next town
over
okay you're the one going in there
getting your [ __ ] head knocked around
just keep your [ __ ] money
so congratulations to them for one of
the uh best pay-per-views i've seen in a
long time and you know what's so funny
is like boxing's been in such a shitty
way they kept telling me during that
this yeah you're really getting your
money's worth that's a great
pay-per-view they just kept telling me
what a great pit it's like i know it is
i'm sorry a youtube star is digging it
you you left the [ __ ] door open
by running your business so [ __ ] up
that a youtube star is taking food off
of your plate they must have said
this is unbelievably exciting and worth
the money in roundabout ways
at least once around i felt um
but anyway jesus christ
jesus christ i would have been terrified
if i was a ref 269 277 the other guy is
one of six something in [ __ ] 240
and they're slipping punches and i'm
just like i i do not want to be the that
you know those youtube those [ __ ]
youtube blooper things in boxing
with a box of [ __ ] slips of punch
it's usually a hook
he misses and he punches the ref
oh
jeez a glancing blow from either one of
them might have to learn how to talk
again
um anyway
so uh i've been watching some baseball
because my red sox socks
um
are playing the temporary devil rays who
have just owned our asses for i don't
know how long
seemingly forever
and uh
game one they came out
and their [ __ ] starting pitcher gave
us the right there fred just pitched a
[ __ ]
gem
and it was four to nothing and i'm
watching
and some kids up and we call this shift
and there's a guy on [ __ ] third base
so there's nobody covering third the
guy's halfway up the [ __ ]
line and we have a lefty on the mound
who like his wind up it was longer than
it takes me to tie my shoes
he [ __ ]
just took off and he stole on plate
so
it's much as it sucked to watch my team
lose game one that's an exciting play to
watch and then game two
was just like a video game like no
matter how many runs either team scored
it wasn't enough
i want to say we scored two and then
they scored five in the first inning
then we came back and somehow we were up
like six or seven to five and then they
came back scored a couple we were like
eight to it was like eight to five
or eight to four maybe
and then they scored two more runs all
of a sudden it's eight to six it's like
we're really gonna have to score 10
i think i came up with the score was
like 14 to eight or something it was
some [ __ ] crazy
crazy game bats came alive
and as much as i was excited about the
bats coming live i was like well you
know we also gave up
six seven eight runs that's not too
exciting
so then it comes back to boston
and we played today i spent the whole
day with my son so i missed the game i
just saw the highlights
and uh red sox walk-off two-run homer
and either the 12th or the 13th inning
amazing i saw some devil raised fans
whining about uh
you know they [ __ ] us over in a
[ __ ] obscure rule man no
they applied it properly and you were
unfamiliar with the rule as was i but it
is a rule
the big conspiracy theory that they're
trying to help out the larger markets
it's like that's not how they help out
the larger markets they help out the
larger markets by having a luxury tax
um that george steinbrenner completely
took advantage of
it was ridiculous
um
which i felt was you know
way more cheating than [ __ ] banging
on a trash can and then the red my red
sox followed him right over the cliff
and we started spending 182 million
dollars like
you know and some other was going
[ __ ] it's fixed it's like that's not
how you fix a game but you don't call a
rule correctly
for those who didn't watch the game
basically one of the double rays
hit a ball and there was a guy on base
that would have scored
but the ball hit off the red sox player
and went into the crowd and if it's
incidental contact if he didn't do it on
purpose it's a ground rule double so
that guy had to go back to third
so it sucked for them it's just one of
those [ __ ] things but it is the
proper
application of the rule so you just got
to kind of take it sometimes it doesn't
go your [ __ ] way
you know
um
yeah but if you're going to fix a game
you pay off an umpire and he does it
with the strike zone you're not going to
be we're going to fix this game gee i
really hope this guy hits the ball and
it incidentally glances off another
player so he can [ __ ] him out of a run
in the 12th inning that's not how you
fix the game sorry
that goes back to that [ __ ] i
remember
there's always somebody saying
especially the [ __ ] cults those
[ __ ] [ __ ]
always talking about cheating you know
i like the tuck rule that was another
one one of the funniest things i ever
saw was raider fans talking about
cheating who literally that is their
motto
if you ain't cheating you ain't trying
the most penalized team
in professional sports history and just
the amount of cheating that they did i
mean if all you got to do is read any
autobiography from a [ __ ] raider in
the 70s the [ __ ] that those guys used to
do was [ __ ] hilarious so um whatever
i hate when people [ __ ] whine about
[ __ ] like that
um which i probably have done when my
team loses but i mean hey what are you
gonna do it is what it is it is what it
is it is a [ __ ] rule um
but i got to tell you something watching
um postseason baseball first of all
unbelievably exciting and then secondly
um
the the home run celebrations that these
kids do nowadays
i swear to god is the reason why you
cannot take fighting out of hockey
there's always these these [ __ ]
[ __ ] who don't watch hockey or don't
understand the game
they're always saying you got to get
fighting out of hockey
and it's like look at baseball look what
happened to baseball now that a pitcher
can't [ __ ] throw it a hitter
i mean these [ __ ] i mean when we
double race hits a home run he's [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] yelling at the
dugout he looks like a wrestler coming
out from behind the curtain he's
pointing
i don't know like this is my [ __ ]
stadium he's stumping his [ __ ] chest
he's pointing up to his dead uncle in
heaven
and he hasn't even gotten to first base
yet
the [ __ ] third base coach is is is
gesticulating less than this [ __ ] guy
walking out and
that's what happens
that guy would never do that [ __ ] when i
grew up because if he did one of those
[ __ ] things the next guy would take
one right between the [ __ ] numbers
and then the next time he came out he'd
throw it his [ __ ] head
but nowadays
as a baseball player you can go up to
bat with half a [ __ ] football helmet
on with that thing covering your face
right and then you can have like a suit
of armor from your shoulder your lead
[ __ ] arm
and just hang out over the plate
dude the other side of the plate the
pitcher used to own that that was it you
weren't getting that [ __ ] you
all right you could have the middle of
plate to the inside that's you but that
outside of the plate that is [ __ ]
mine and if you try taking that from me
i'm gonna act like you said something to
my wife and i'm throwing right at your
[ __ ] head that's what happened
okay
that's what watching these [ __ ] kids
do it's so [ __ ] it's so now the
pitchers do it they strike some of the
other [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] awesome
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then they [ __ ] going
to the dugouts hilarious
i don't i guess maybe i'm just an old
guy but i'm just watching it going like
i i don't understand
just don't understand that
you know
you're not allowed to be in the paint
anymore so you dunk on nobody and then
after you do that you just look at the
opposing
fan base under the under the net you
just go
[Music]
it's just all like that you know look at
me i'm a beast
but then if you go to dunk the ball and
you [ __ ] up and it goes off the back of
the rim and goes back to half court then
what do you do
i just go oops you just sort of
sort of jog back
you know you strike out i mean i don't
know it's just funny watching people
talking [ __ ] in baseball
when all you got to do is be successful
three out of 10 times
which is what i did in math class that i
had to go to summer school every year
these [ __ ] [ __ ] go to the hall of
fame
i'm sorry i'm just [ __ ] around i just
i really hate
self-congratulatory [ __ ] i'm a beast
[ __ ] when you know it's just like
you know
just and then enough
enough
i get it like you're not the first
person to ever hit a home run hit a
[ __ ] home run and run around the
bases okay i don't need your [ __ ]
what are they yelling about what i just
wanna be miked up what is he saying
did you see that it went over the fence
that's exactly what i was supposed to do
in this stadium right now
were the other guys on the bench saying
he couldn't do it did he just win some
money i just don't understand what the
[ __ ] they're yelling at
um
i don't know how about those new england
patriots
getting their asses whipped by the
[ __ ] houston texans then all of a
sudden
what do they do they make one of the
numbers they make for the number one
mistake you don't do in football don't
get [ __ ] cute
fourth and two you've decided to punt
punt the [ __ ] ball what do these
[ __ ] jerk-offs do
what do they do
huh
evidently they went to go see joel
olsteen and joel osteen was like god
wants you to act like it's a fake punk
he wants you to go out there and act
like you're going to be a quarterback
and then back up but not far enough so
you booted and it goes off your
lineman's ass for zero yards god wants
you to do that
and i resented all the people that said
i look like that guy it's like make up
your mind okay
well i thought i looked like the buffalo
bills coach what because they're [ __ ]
5-0
currently playing the chiefs
you know now i don't look like that guy
i only look like the people that [ __ ] up
when the bills suck
mcdermott or whatever his name is is
building the goddamn team uh you know
that's when i look like them but now
they're undefeated
how come i can't still be that guy i
want to be that guy
you know he's not paying for any wings
in that [ __ ] godforsaken town
the bermuda triangle of the rust belt
the sports bermuda triangle of the rust
belt
the buffalo bills i literally tweeted
today i was like uh the [ __ ] patriots
dude right because we uh scored a
touchdown to tie it up or whatever and
some guy just write congrat wow you're
beating the worst team in the league and
i'm like who's this [ __ ]
right
so i look at his profile and i just see
all this buffalo [ __ ] sabers and [ __ ]
the bills and i'm like oh that's what it
is
sorry
we've been [ __ ] you guys in the ass
twice a year in the regular season for
the last [ __ ] 20 something years i
get it
i get it you haven't beaten us since jim
kelly was there is that what it is
maybe he beat us once or twice
i get it so that was an easy win for me
i just
it's just
why as as a buffalo fan would you ever
talk [ __ ] your trophy cases
are empty
they're empty
you've never
won
anything i'm sorry they might have won
an afl title
was that the chargers i used to know the
i used to know all the afl champions
let's look this up let me let me put
some respect on these wings for buffalo
afl
champions
list
[ __ ] not not soccer
afl
football football will still do that afl
put chargers in there because i know
that they want it
afl championships pro football hall game
okay here we go
donna no not
okay the houston oilers in 1960 beat the
los angeles chargers the houston oilers
are now the tennessee titans and los
angeles chargers are now the los angeles
chargers
for a brief time from 1961 to 2017 they
were the san diego chargers
um houston oilers next year they beat
the san diego chargers
1963 the san diego chargers finally
51-10 drubbing of the boston patriots
boston patriots later becoming the new
england patriots trying to draw all
states fans in
that's the only reason why buffalo bills
defeat the san diego chargers dude the
chargers went every [ __ ] you look at
this
chargers chargers
oh no they didn't go the second the
dallas texans now the kansas city chiefs
all right 1964 the buffalo bills there
it is
and they wanted 65.
would you look at that
then around 67 68 they get oj simpson
oh jay simpson loving that [ __ ]
cold town of white women
oh [ __ ] um anyway
so after that they called a fake they
acted like they were gonna do a fake
punt and then the guy was supposed to
quickly you know hoping that the return
man would run up
which he did
and then all of a sudden the punter is
trying to run back and boot the ball
over his head before the guy has a
chance to run back the punter got blamed
it's a [ __ ] up it's like i don't know
it was a [ __ ] up uh
you know it was a [ __ ] up uh i don't
know call you know i realized i never
finished my hockey fighting thing
so now that you can't throw the [ __ ]
ball at
these goddamn
hitters
like you just see how awful their
[ __ ] behavior is now every time they
hit a [ __ ] home run
right
and that's
like fighting if you just took the
fighting out of hockey
and some [ __ ] like trying to end your
career all he's going to get is a
five-minute major or a [ __ ] 10-minute
game misconduct
worst-case scenario the occasional
10-game suspension
um
you can't just take the fighting out of
it you'd have to take the fighting out
and then you'd have to get rid of all
the dirty players
you'd have to get rid of all of that
you have to get rid of all of the
sociopaths
um
yeah you can't do that you need the
fighting in the game
to keep people [ __ ] their sticks down
and all of that [ __ ] and you need
pitchers to be able to [ __ ] drill the
next guy
you know
in the [ __ ] ribs
so you don't have to watch somebody
screaming into the dugout
like they just i don't know what they
just [ __ ] won a war or something
um they did win a war at the plate man
um
all right
anyway
so some devil race fans are [ __ ]
whining i don't know why they're whining
okay they [ __ ] want a stanley cup and
they just want a [ __ ] super bowl
you know i mean one goddamn thing goes
doesn't go your [ __ ] way what is the
problem okay and not to mention you end
up losing by two
so quit your crime all right anyway i uh
sorry i don't know what this is very
sports heavy day
um yeah so i basically uh i spent my day
whole day with my kids today it was
awesome
and um around midday my wife
took my daughter
to her uncle's house for a birthday
party so then i just spent like the rest
of the afternoon with my son and we had
we
had the best
frigging time first of all my daughter
out of nowhere just started telling me
that she wanted an apple pie
and i was like you want an apple pie and
she's like yes
dad do you know how to make an apple pie
i was like i do i do know how to make an
apple pie she goes okay can you make it
tonight
like well i don't think we have enough
apples here so uh i
well i need can you go to the store and
you know tell me all that stuff so
for some reason she told me she wanted
it for breakfast
so i was like all right
so i said okay
i can't remember if i already told you
guys the story so i say to my wife like
all right i gotta go to the grocery
store and get
some apples and stuff and she's just
like bill
you can't keep doing this instant
gratification
they're gonna you know
you're gonna spoil them and blah blah
blah i'm like you're right you're right
you're right overcompensating
for the way i grew up
can i have an apple pie
no
what is it [ __ ] christmas
oh
i was shut the [ __ ] up
right that [ __ ]
so um
yeah so i try to [ __ ] you know
overcompensate i think i'm doing a good
job because there's definitely a line
it's definitely i have a line but my
line is it's it's pretty far down the
road like you have to do
um
like i can't think of anything that
really upsets me that my kids do
oh they scream in my ear that's what
kills me when they're play fighting
that's screeching and my ears already
ring because i got the [ __ ] tinnitus
there
i'll be like oh my god just don't yell
into my ear like that
so sometimes i literally wear like
earplugs from smart
because they're going to be squealing or
whatever so anyway um
yeah so i made this apple pie
and my son had it for the first time it
was just like gr he had like like
took a bite and he started
had like you know two shoes of it and he
just looks up at his big grin
like what is this
so uh when my wife left she said i was
like all right what what should i give
him for
lunch
she was like you get something you know
some fruit and a little bit of this that
if you want you could have deserted you
have a little bit of apple pie i'm like
okay that's happening so uh we hung out
and did that
i was watching football with him
he has a little bit of a cold this
[ __ ] lingering cold
whatever the hell this thing is that's
going around
um
so i took a steam with the
you know
i took a steam with them the other day
too i had one of the worst moments as a
dad ugh
took a steam with him he was kind of
wriggling around and everything i was
like i can't you know because the
steam's coming out you know
i only had him in you know i had it
turned down low
just to get this stuff because kids
don't know how to blow their nose right
so he had he got up
i ended up setting him down i wasn't
even thinking i'm like okay the steam's
off so he won't get burned or anything
and he [ __ ] walked and he came i know
you guys know this he [ __ ] he was
standing up and then he wasn't
i i turned away for two seconds to set
this thing what was he doing he was
oh my wife had like some sort of spray
bottle that he kept trying to get to and
he just fortunately landed mostly on his
ass
and then but then he hit the back of his
head just ever so like not bad i know
that sounds horrible oh and he started
crying i felt
[ __ ] so bad
be still beating myself up to that
but it was like it went from like the
greatest moment like taking a steam with
your son and some you know guy [ __ ]
right
hanging out
and uh
you know he was enjoying it he thought
it was sort of fascinating and you know
the crap was coming out of his nose and
then after a while i was just kind of
like all right this is too hot and then
it's when i went to take him out but uh
then we did it again the next day and i
made sure that he didn't fall down but
jesus is there anything [ __ ] worse
than when your kid gets hurt on your
watch oh my god
ugh
my wife's cool she goes don't beat
yourself up about it it happens like
he's falling out of the bed
you know when he i you know i set him
down he rolled off out of the bed and
blah blah you know they're resilient
they get back up and stuff i was like
yeah did you feel good after it happened
she's like no i got all right all right
that's what i'm going through here
but um anyway we did that and then uh i
took him for a walk through the
neighborhood put him in the uh the
stroller and all that stuff and uh
just had an awesome time with them
he's a really really good kid
likes throwing the ball he's strong as
hell and i'm finding he's really he's
into music
and which is really cool like he makes a
b-line
got this little uh
toy piano thing and he just makes a
b-line for and he loves it
and if i start playing i got a little
acoustic guitar if i play a little bit
strum a few chords
he has a big grin and he walks over and
he listens and he reaches out he wants
to try and play it it's so
[ __ ] cool
so we'll see we'll see um
worst case scenario he's just a music
lover best case scenario we have a drum
battle
you know or maybe he [ __ ] picks up
the guitar or whatever my daughter loves
playing guitar who knows who knows i
could jam with my kids can you imagine
that
one plays bass one plays guitar
am i turning into joe jackson here but
i'm not i don't put him on the road i
just want to [ __ ] jam with them teach
him an ac dc song
highway to hell it's an easy one
right ah
fun days fun days ahead all right so
here we go
let's uh let's do some reads here
some reads here for the week
um
where am i going here oh indochito
you know the right outfit can bring out
something special in us
and within docino creating your best
look yet
could be more affordable than you think
talk about any special occasion
occasions that have been postponed over
the year
or any events that are coming up soon
that you are looking forward to well my
entire uh
stand-up tour of last year was canceled
what am i looking forward to i am
looking forward to uh
a bunch of stuff that i can't talk about
that literally is gonna get announced
here in the next cup tomorrow i think
but as far as what i have on the books i
am looking forward to going to milwaukee
i got that coming up i got atlanta this
weekend
i got long beach and all of those things
last time i played long beach you know
what i wore a suit i did i mean that
that's the terrace theater that's where
richard pryor live in concert when he
has the red shirt the black pants
and the silver shoes and he pulled up
to the venue was [ __ ] amazing and uh
and it looks the exact same
and i couldn't believe that i was
playing there so um
yeah it wouldn't be that wouldn't be bad
to get a indochino suit um anyway maybe
been a while since the last time you had
an excuse to dress up but whenever that
next chance is makes an abs make the
absolute most of it
within docino indochino offers
completely custom fitted suit shirts
casual wear and more at surprisingly
affordable prices every piece is made to
your exact measurements and you can
customize every detail the best part
indochino suit started just 3.99
with all customizations included
indochino is now open at select
nordstrom stores look at them
moving up
uh giving you even more ways to get
great fitting personalized clothing find
your nearest location at i-n-d-o-c-a
dot com
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com
right now you can get 50 off any
purchase of 3.99
or more by using code burr at checkout
that's fifty dollars off of purchase at
39 and now
oh that's going to get annoying quick or
more at
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o dot com i-n-d-o
dot com promo code burr
all right
i just pictured every guy listening to
this right now with his girlfriend being
like oh god can you shut that guy off
all right and i just got one thing to
say [ __ ] you lady uh kidding kidding
ladies i'm sorry isn't this the the
month of the women
have you noticed the pink [ __ ] has come
back i just saw that at the bills
[ __ ] uh
kansas city game you're sitting there
you're trying to decompress the end of
the [ __ ] week you know
you got a bunch of [ __ ] coming up and
then all of a sudden he's hold up aside
hey by the way my dad died of cancer oh
thank you thank you for telling me that
fantastic i have friends that died of
cancer i'm not going to bring that up
when you're trying to watch a [ __ ]
ball game
um
for the life of me i don't understand
what that moment is about what is that
moment about i have no [ __ ] idea what
is it about okay well how come we don't
have a game where everybody hey you know
let's talk about i don't know
the mumps that's the disease is that a
disease is it an affliction is it a
virus
um
i don't care what it is
it's a [ __ ] conspiracy the mumps
never even happened
i don't even sound like nothing does it
the mumps
uh zip recruiter every oh separate
you know there are some things in life
that i like to pick out myself
like my wife
i picked her out all by myself you know
in some parts of the world you don't get
that privilege
uh so i know that i've got the one
that's best for me
like cuts of steak mattresses bottles of
wine
what if you can do the same thing for
hiring everybody
yes try to wrap your head around that
choose your ideal candidate before they
even apply
what
um is this the blow your mind copy uh
that's where zip
recruiter invites invite to apply comes
in it gives you as the hiring manager
the power to pick your favorite
top from top candidate candidates sorry
and right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
how does invite to apply work
glad you asked well when you post a job
on zip
they find you the most qualified people
for your job then you can easily review
the candidates and invite your top
choices to apply for your job it's like
a dating app
except you're trying to find somebody
to do the job
all right
you're not wait you're not [ __ ] this
person you're you're trying to fill a
cubicle
lauren webb senior vice president of
talent acquisitions for
medulla
mind ola
health raves about zip recruiters invite
to apply she says
i love that feature i love that feature
because
we have a much higher follow through
rate if i invite candidates it's easy
for me
and it's easy for them
well thank you lauren webb senior vice
president of talent acquisition for
medulla health
i'll be honest with you i didn't think
she was raving about it
i mean a lot of people throw around the
l word i just love it in fact according
to zip
recruiter
internal data
jobs where employees use zip
girder
invite to apply get on average two and a
half times more candidates which helps
for a faster hiring process see for
yourself
just go to this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
burr b-u-r-r to try zip
for free that's ziprecruiters.com
the smartest way
to hire
oh
what the [ __ ] is this i love the name of
this already
solo stove
jesus christ i'm picturing somebody just
divorced
you know are you divorced did your wife
take everything from you and you don't
have any [ __ ] money left but you
still want to cook something
why have four burners
you're alone in this world
introducing
solo stove one burner one person one
life go [ __ ] yourself here's some
[ __ ] bacon uh there's nothing quite
like the feeling of gathering around a
warm fire on a cool fall evening
yeah especially if they [ __ ] knock
the clocks back
who wants to sit by a fire in the
daylight
and a smokeless fire pit from solo stove
makes your outdoor moments even more
memorable wait what is this i already
like this thing because instead of
having to constantly dodge campfire
fumes you can sit back relax and
actually enjoy the fire
wait i gotta see what this [ __ ] thing
looks like solo stove i just love that
name
it has nothing to do i thought it was
like a [ __ ]
i thought it was
one like burner and then underneath a
little [ __ ] door that you would just
make a casserole for one
solo stove
i mean that is just [ __ ] tremendous
all right images i gotta see
look at that thing and it looks nice
solo stove bonfire it looks like a giant
one of those uh you know those things
that you stick under trays of food
looks like a candle then they light it
and everybody's like
then you have orange chicken in a fight
with your wife on the way home
um is the salt and [ __ ]
sugar are messing with your brain
all right
because instead of having to constantly
dodge campfire fumes you can sit back
relax and enjoy the fire upgrade your
backyard with a solo stove fire pit
enjoying the warm ambiance
the mesmerizing flames all right they're
getting crazy with this
look at whoever wrote this after you use
ambiance okay that's enough big words
for my listeners you can't use ambiance
and two seconds later say mesmerizing
mesmerizing flames
what do we burn in here then all of a
sudden i'm just going hey man
look at those flames
uh and all the opportunities to create
more good moments and lasting memories
make the time with your friends and
family richer
with a solo stove fire pit
solo stove fire pits are brilliantly
engineered and beautifully crafted i'm
not gonna lie to you it does look great
made with premium grade 304 stainless
steel
and a patented 360 degree airflow system
that maximizes efficiency with while
minimizing smoke
that's the big thing huh
easy to light with a few few bits of
starter your fire is blazing in minutes
perfectly portable take solo stove with
you on camping trips and more get the
perfect fire pit for those fall nights
and make your backyard a destination
oh we gotta get over the stage he's got
a [ __ ] solo stove with a spectacular
fire pit from
solo stove
you know something
that's right solo stove is right up
there with smoke monday
my two [ __ ] favorite names of the
fall
um shop the fall event now and get an
extra 10 off when you use promo code bur
at checkout they're so confident you'll
love it
they offer a lifetime warranty and a
30-day
free return policy just go to solo stove
and remember you get 10 off when you use
the promo code burr
i mean you got a fire pit and there's no
smoke
it's perfect
um all right
please mention that your new dates will
be announced tuesday on billbird.com i
did mention that i have my whole
celebrating 30 years of stand-up comment
30 years of my ignorant [ __ ] thoughts
how in god's name
was my first show 30 years ago i got to
be honest with you it seems like forever
ago
um
which by the way the great jim norton
posted something on his instagram an
article
his first article he ever had written up
about him
um
from 1990
and we're the same age i'm actually a
little bit older than him
and i was like i had no idea i thought
he we started right around the same time
but
that had him in 1990. i have to ask him
that when he started
because if by 1999 if he already had an
article written about about him he must
have been doing it
at least a year and then i'm thinking
like did he start in the 80s
i wish i started in the 80s i would have
loved to have seen what that was like
because i started right after the whole
thing went right in this [ __ ]
um
the big 80s stand-up boom was over
um all right all my tour dates will be
announced on billburr.com
b-i-l-l-b-u-r-r
dot-com yes um i almost said [ __ ] all
right bill burr is a jack-o-lantern
what is this
um good morning bill every year a local
park in louisville kentucky
oh keep that you know something
i'm gonna tease louisville kentucky
that might be
on my tour next year i'm not sure
i'm not allowed to announce it yet uh
louisville holds the jack-o'-lantern
spectacular you know something i would
love to go to that
my wife would love to go to that
a huge halloween event with a trail of
artistically carved jack-o-lanterns
i just attended
sorry
i just attended last night and was
thrilled to see a pumpkin carved with
your face
and i had to send it along get the [ __ ]
out of here
my husband and i are a huge fan love
your podcast we've seen your live show
and you were fantastic on the
mandalorian thank you and king of staten
island of course thank you all the best
to you nia and your family thank you
texted the pictures yes
he did oh so that's where that was from
that was that was from
[Music]
uh i gotta answer this i'm wide
open
all right where is it where is it let's
see the [ __ ] jack-o'-lantern
billy oh billy pumping that jesus christ
that's [ __ ] amazing
i like that cool coat you gave me
that is [ __ ] wild
i'm going to send that to my wife so she
thinks i'm important
why would somebody waste that time
[ __ ] your orange anyway and it's
[ __ ]
um no i'm kidding oh speaking of orange
mario batali by the way
i i am like
blown away by like uh
those pumpkins that people carve like
those really like [ __ ] amazingly
talented people
like the coolest one i ever did was the
federal reserve when i was in the
conspiracy theory
um
i made that because i was like this is
the scariest this should be the scariest
thing on halloween i was insufferable
i'm not saying i wasn't right but i mean
nobody once i realized nobody cares i
just i just don't have the fight in me
that's like with the vaccine like i gave
a [ __ ] i gave a [ __ ] and i gave a [ __ ]
and half of you didn't so just like i
don't give a [ __ ] whatever i don't care
anyways
speaking of pumpkins
mario batali
somebody wrote mario batali got
cancelled just as an fyi mario batali
got cancelled
why would you think i don't know this i
was a fan of the guy
i still am as far as his cooking goes
you know what i mean i still love o.j
simpson you know what he did on the
football field okay i don't get into the
after hour [ __ ] once mario stops cooking
i mean i don't know what happened
uh he got cancelled for a bunch of
sexual assault accusations
i actually um this is a confession i
have i have a mario batali
crock pot whatever you call it thing's
[ __ ] great it's got a big m on it we
call it the me too pot
um
what am i supposed to throw it out
throw it in the [ __ ] ocean
the pot didn't do anything uh wouldn't
we wouldn't be praising him on your
podcast i know it sucks as a chef i used
to watch his show all the time he's a
[ __ ] incredible cook
he is
[ __ ] amazing i learned so much about
italy through the guy and he came up
with the easily which i love going to
that too
having said that you know you shouldn't
be taking out your [ __ ] uh pumpkin
[ __ ] at work i mean i i
i see the whole thing
anyways the guy says i hate cancelled
cultures not much as the next person
well i think cancer culture is different
than that if you actually [ __ ] did
[ __ ] like that
they got the right person and that
started because no one was listening to
these women
who are getting assaulted allegedly i
don't know if it's been proved i don't
know what
um
they were getting insulted by these guys
like they shouldn't have had to [ __ ]
deal with that just because they work
with the guy that that part is all good
that part is all fine
it's then what
[ __ ] did with that
they took that and then ran with it
to like
he was mean to me
he didn't say hi to me when i said hi to
him in 1994 you should end his career
then it became [ __ ] like that then it
just became stupid anyway the guy says i
hate canceled culture as much as the
next person we're supposed to be a
nation that exemplifies due process
and innocence until proven guilty well i
mean yeah
that's what we say but i mean
how many documentaries do you have to
[ __ ] watch
about what we've done to people
specifically who aren't right
um but just wanted to let you know
because there's so much crap out there
don't want the wolves coming after you
bill well you know
the thing about me is i've always said
this my career is the punishment you
know it's usually
they usually try to
take a tv show away from you or end your
movie career or [ __ ] whatever the
[ __ ] it is
and back in the day you just you know
now you're gonna have to just go back
and do stand-up but now what's going on
is you can make so much [ __ ] money
doing stand-up now they're trying to
take that away you know what i mean if
you're a guy if you're a chick they
don't give a [ __ ]
anyways says god bless you and yours
can't wait for your next comedy album
stand up well i appreciate that i
appreciate you looking out for me i
realized that the man
was canceled i do understand that um
he wasn't canceled he was exposed
evidently for whatever the [ __ ] he was
doing after work
and uh
yeah and that's what happens
so
but having said that the guy can cook
his ass off you know what i mean
i used to do this joke about o.j simpson
something like that i was just like
listen
how the [ __ ] did it go
you know i i can separate the two i can
look at o.j
you know for what he did on the football
field he was [ __ ] amazing having said
that i don't condone the way the man
handled his
um no ball busting in college
and plastic death
um
okay dear billy translucent skin
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um
the guy says i'm off topic here
what is this where did i see that
i think i just scrolled into something
else here tres i'm a blue collar guy
where did i just see i'm off topic here
anyway oh it says off topic right there
okay i'm a blue collar guy with a job in
a university in your home state
of massachusetts
um
buddy
i moved away from there almost half my
life ago all right how long do i claim
that place i go back now i i don't i
don't recognize any city now every city
has been turned into one giant
luxury apartment building i feel
um i've been observing how odd
professors are they
they lack the lack of eye contact and a
sense of humor forget sarcasm and worse
this is carrie carrying over to the
students
i've always been the guy at work that
makes people laugh and has a good time
but this place is draining
it's an easy job but i don't know if i
can stay here seven years till i retire
uh oh he's at a university i've been
observing how odd the professors are
they lack the lack of eye contact and
sense of humor
this is carrying over to the students
yeah well
there's going to be a big
pushback on that
you know
it just is you can't you just can't run
any further in that direction
and then it just has to go the other way
so it'll be fine it'll correct itself
anyways he says off topic xfinity center
great woods bro oh is that what they're
calling it now
sells liquid death
but you have to put it in plastic cups
yes they won't give you the can what the
[ __ ]
oh my god corporate [ __ ] lawyers once
again afraid someone's gonna get sued
it's so dumb it is so dumb that is the
number one [ __ ] thing we should all
be talking about
is how we can stop [ __ ]
doing things to this planet that's not
gonna make it sustainable for us to live
here
oh well thanks for being angry enough
for the both of us and go [ __ ] yourself
you know i don't think i'm that angry
i'm angrier than the next guy
uh but you know i have built i've built
this house on anger so whatever
you know i need to do one of those fluff
pieces
you know
let those stars always do in like people
magazine a little older a little wiser
has finally found love
letting go knows who her friends are i'm
gonna do one of those fluff pieces
let's let go of the anger
all right my staff is running me out of
my company
well jesus christ you got a mutiny going
on here hi bill blue balls i am writing
from latin america nice english is not
my first language so apologies
beforehand
hablo espanol
um
oh your english seems great so far i am
the owner
of a woman's underwear retail concept
fancy enough for you uh what does
concept mean i employ only women as it
is difficult for us guys to select and
sell these products
oh yeah you want a woman's if you're
making women's underwear you want a
woman to be like i would wear that i
like that
uh where is the crotch in that one you
[ __ ] pervert all right so you know
trying some out uh let's just say
women do a better job at picking and
selling bras and panties than you or me
would do exactly i do have 30 plus years
experience in managing these products
and have a good understanding so
basically my teams
my team does day to day i do
oversight mind you this is a small ass
business wait english is your second
language and you say this is a small ass
business that's pretty impressive uh
three stores and a web sale
and web sales sorry uh the thing is i
have a team i take good care of all
women they manage their schedule all six
of them have kids and come and go as
they please as long as they do the work
whenever we are together i would try to
get lunch blah blah blah and all that oh
you pay for it i think i was a good boss
now as the team grew bigger nothing i
say or do is appreciate it you are not a
woman you don't understand if i stress
too much i'm pushing if i let loose i am
out of touch bill i just cannot win with
these ladies well what the [ __ ] dude you
never hung around with women before
what you think was going to be easier
nothing i do is okay yeah you sound like
every married guy you know i am the
drive i am driving the web sales putting
much emphasis on it as you should know
nowadays and anything i try to implement
they don't like i become a scared shell
of a man second guesser of myself and
everything and i find myself pitching
things to my staff scared they will not
like it all right you lost your
confidence you got to get a victory
uh thing is three weeks ago i got fed up
and had the i've had it with you moment
and have not been back to the office
only digital communication
oh dude you gave up the castle i know
this is not a long-term solution also
three months ago had a heart attack i'm
and came out of it better than before
but apparently with no tolerance for
[ __ ] bill what can i do thank you
for all you do and go [ __ ] yourself all
right the first thing you do is you
don't argue with women
all right you just get quiet to say
something you don't agree at the end of
the day dude you're the boss so they
don't have any [ __ ] power over you
unless you give it to them
all right so what you have to [ __ ] do
is you have to be
um
it's the seinfeld thing master your
domain except you're talking about your
emotions
all right you're not doing anything
wrong you're employing everybody there
you're letting them come and go as they
please you're being a great boss
according to you
and
you know all you're doing is pitching
ideas
all right
so um
what would i do um
if there's an idea i believe in i
wouldn't give a [ __ ] what they say i'd
stick with it
and that that's a way to build back up
your confidence and i guess you know to
show them that you know everything that
they say i think you you've over
you've kind of let the nuts run the nut
house um
i've never done this i've never run a
small business like this but uh
i don't know why you had a heart attack
did you have a heart attack because of
stress or because of the way you were
eating were you stress eating i have no
idea it's a lot of variables here this
one's a little out of my [ __ ]
um
wheelhouse and i got issues with women
obviously so i'm probably not the best
person
to
to talk to um
and most of my issues with women have to
do with not being wanting to be
controlled i don't like when people try
to [ __ ] control me plan out my day
tell me what i need to wear and all of
that [ __ ] it drives me up the [ __ ]
wall especially if i'm not doing it to
you
i don't like people like that male or
female and if you get into a
relationship i don't know if it's a
motherly instinct it's just sort of
uh you know what happens and i i just
yeah
not jesus i don't know if i answered
your [ __ ] question um
i will tell you this you need to go into
work or they're going to start stealing
underwear from you all right
well the cat's away the mice will play
as they say so that's the first thing i
would do
secondly you had the heart attack you
can use that to your advantage and say
listen i don't need heightened emotions
i'm on the other side of a heart attack
okay uh
yeah i would just you just need sort of
a more respectable
back and forth then i would you know
i don't know it's always dangerous to
tell women what you're thinking
just try what i just said there and you
know something i would also phone a
friend here
try to get some better [ __ ] advice i
don't know what to tell you
um that's a hell of a situation you're
in there though uh but i'm glad you
didn't die from your heart attack and i
hope that you're eating some [ __ ]
greens and chilling the [ __ ] out maybe
headspace
headspace meditation
um
or you could also introduce a line of
men's briefs boxer briefs why don't you
do that and then at least that's one
place where they'll have to shut up
even then they'll still chime in
i wouldn't [ __ ] a guy if he's wearing
those
all right thank you ladies all right
girlfriends wardrobe malfunction holy
[ __ ] wardrobe malfunction
um all right billy the bambino of bimbo
bashing burr
wow how the hell are you i need some
advice i will do us both a favor and try
to keep this short no promises though i
too have been known
to go off on long rants sorry i'm
yawning here here's my story
my girlfriend and i and i decided to
host a small bbq
pool pool party oh what could go wrong
we figured oh jesus bikinis oh no
i'm just hoping it's a titty and her
clam didn't fall out you know
but you never know
that you jump off the diving board and
try to touch your toes [ __ ] spread
eagle doing the david lee roth and her
[ __ ]
p lip came out um all right my
girlfriend and i okay we figured it
would be the perfect opportunity to get
everyone together again now that most if
not all of us have been vaccinated
anyway the bbq is going great
i'm in charge of the grill my lady
who is a truly gorgeous woman woman is
doing the rounds mingling everyone seems
to be having a good time what can go
wrong you ask i will tell you bill oh no
at one point i walked over to my girl to
bring her a plate of food
she was talking to a good buddy of mine
who i've been friends with for over 20
years and i had
as i go to hand her the plate
lo and behold her bikini top
has left her left nipple completely
unattended
i'm talking janet jackson complete
wardrobe malfunction bill very
noticeable impossible to miss
i blurt out something like jesus christ
hun put that away at which point she
turns away to deal with the runaway boob
visibly embarrassed yeah he probably
shouldn't have yelled that [ __ ] my buddy
pretending that he had not noticed at
all lets out a whoa and turns to look
away and cover his eyes obviously it
became very awkward and uncomfortable
but as they say the show must go on yeah
now you got to look at your buddy like
dude you [ __ ] saw the titty there's
no way a titty comes out and a guy
doesn't notice the woman's gorgeous
the party continued though i did not
have the whole incident though i did
have the whole instant stewing in the
back of my mind after everyone left i
spoke to my girl about it turns out
she'd been talking to my buddy for over
10 minutes and not once did he mention
anything being a man myself i have to
think that he was able to expertly
maintain eye contact
while checking out the full moon version
of a nipple slip with his periphery
all the while uploading the image into
his spank bank oh god
this is what sucks about being a guy i
haven't told her this but i find myself
also upset at her
though i know it does not make any sense
and it is probably the result of
misdirected feelings that's exactly what
it is but a piece of me feels it's her
responsibility to keep her tits covered
up
well what's funny is if your balls were
hanging out she'd be like how the [ __ ]
did you not know your balls were hanging
up
um to add
how could she not have noticed that her
nipple was basking in the florida sun i
mean i can sense the mildest breeze when
i have plumbers cracked on display i
just
choose to ignore it
um
my question to you bill is should i
confront my buddy
about this to clear the air or will it
just make things more weird
i am almost certain he's just going to
deny any wrong well how can you prove
how long it was out you don't know when
it came out
how could he not it's not like he's
going to apologize and admit being a
douche or
offer to show me his girl's tit do i
just drop it i don't know bill the whole
thing is just
is not sitting well with me any advice
would be greatly appreciated go [ __ ]
yourself
uh dude i hate to tell you this you're
just gonna have to let it go
it might affect you hanging out with the
guy
um
it's just one of those unfortunate
things um
that happens when you know
you're dating a hot chick that's got a
[ __ ] rack and a bikini top on it
titty comes out
comes out it was just a teddy
you know
just look at it positively he got to see
how lucky you were
i don't know what to tell you dude
sometimes you know what you just gotta
take a loss you learn more from losing
than winning and you just have to go
nuts to sit here and plot revenge and
[ __ ] hate that guy you know who gives
a listen if he goes home and jerks off
to that titty coming out he already
jerked off to her anyway
which is kind of funny because that
means you're living his fantasy
all right
and be honest with yourself are you
going to sit there tell me you never
rubbed one out to one of the friends
chicks that they were dating get the
[ __ ] out of here
okay they never bent down to pick
something out you didn't check out her
ass
you're a guy okay it happens who gives a
[ __ ]
it happens
i gotta be honest with you like i i i
would get over that it would just be
like yeah you know
you know
[ __ ] titty came out what are you
gonna do all right
it's like clements back in the day give
up a home run be there give me another
ball give me another [ __ ] ball he
didn't give a [ __ ]
okay just plowed ahead did not deal with
his emotions
um
let's check out the bills i'll tell you
one thing about the buffalo bills dude
they [ __ ] cover i took the bills last
week laying 17 they won 40 to nothing
number one defense in the league i
believe
let's see
buffalo bills
24 to 13.
going into
wait a second
oh it's halftime
is it only halftime that can't be right
it's got to be oh no it's the beginning
of the fourth quarter 24
13 the [ __ ] guys just
cover
i think they beat the spread every you
know if you live in buffalo
were you smart enough to just bet one
game a week and just bury the bills
every
[ __ ] week how much money would you be
up if you buried the bills and took your
winnings and then doubled it and then
doubled it and doubled it and doubled it
don't do that because you'll that gets
scary it gets scary quick
um all right that's it um i feel like i
was kind of lame with the [ __ ]
answers this week i just i i just had to
answer i don't know what i don't know
you're [ __ ] making women's underwear
and you gotta you have a bunch of female
employees yelling at you what do i do i
don't [ __ ] know
talk to somebody who watches the fashion
channel because that's like
you know i don't know i feel like
someone in that world would know better
and then you know your girlfriend's
titty popped out it happens
it [ __ ] happens
and um
ah god damn it now i'm starting to get
mad at your friend
whoa
you might have to dress the woe
yeah he's your buddy
he should have said something and he
didn't
ah dude see look at now i'm thinking
about it
yeah you might have to kind of cool that
relationship for a minute and then just
wait for him to be like hey
what's going on
i don't know but then you're gonna end
it over a titty
i guess it all goes like how do you feel
about this guy
you know is most of this about your ego
oh my woman my titty right is it that
how much do you like if this guy's like
a real friend of yours if you're real
friend of yours he would have [ __ ]
said something you can't [ __ ] sit
there when your butt buddy's wife's or
girlfriend's titty's just hanging out
you gotta say something
although it was a party
he could have been boozed he could have
been not thinking the right way
you know
it's a [ __ ] difficult thing man
i mean
it's a pool party you know somebody's
gonna have a nip slip it just [ __ ]
happens
you know yeah yeah
i don't know dude you're gonna waste all
of that [ __ ] energy
you know what it is it's it's it's
can't get mad at her you can't get mad
at this situation the thing that you can
get mad at is the phony whoa and then
covering his eyes like he's a [ __ ]
gentleman
it's just like am i to believe that that
it might have believed that it just
happened you know what [ __ ] you got to
say something this guy am i to believe
that the [ __ ] titty came out right
when i was there and you didn't notice
until that [ __ ] second and then you
turned away just be listen dude all
right i don't buy that
her titty came out you knew it came out
you didn't [ __ ] say anything and that
bugs me
i think you know what i think you gotta
say that
jesus christ i'm all over the map
but then how do you say it
over the phone face to face
now you're fighting this guy i just you
just got to be prepared to just have
this friendship end
on that and then if it ends on that
every time he sees you he goes back to
that moment he thinks about your girls
titty i mean this is this is a problem
hey man it's sunday night i didn't want
to think this hard all right that's it
people this is that that is the podcast
for this week
go [ __ ] yourselves and i will check in
on you
on
thursday you